I wanted to create a video on clogged
arteries osteoporosis and vitamin k2 you
may have never heard of vitamin k2 but
it's very different than vitamin k1
vitamin k1 helps clot things and they
even doctors if they want to thin the
blood to prevent clots they'll give
people a drug called chromatin to thin
the blood because it blocks vitamin k1
but vitamin k2 is very very very very
different vitamin k2 works with vitamin
D in calcium metabolism all right so
let's just show you how this works
vitamin d3 has a function absorbing
calcium so it actually what it does is
it allows the calcium to be absorbed by
25 times more than it normally would so
calcium doesn't just travel on its own
it needs help by other vitamins ok
vitamin d3 is is the one that works in
the intestine and helps you absorb the
calcium from the intestine much greater
than if you didn't have it and what
counts it what vitamin D does is it
increases the amount of calcium in the
in the blood now if you have too much
vitamin D you can end up with too much
calcium in the blood it's called
hypercalcemia but the vitamin k2 is the
other part of the transportation because
without vitamin k2 you end up with
plaquing calcium plaquing in the
arteries you end up with all sorts of
extra junk in the joints calcium on the
teeth is tartar in the soft and mainly
in the soft tissues so vitamin k2 helps
deliver that gunk that calcium gunk and
the calcium that's in the blood from the
help of vitamin d3 into the bone so and
the teeth so one of the purposes of
vitamin k2 is make sure you have very
very strong bones with strong calcium
and other minerals and good teeth but
what's really cool is that vitamin k2 is
the most potent inhibitor of vascular
calcification you ever notice when
people get older maybe get stiffer and
they start hunching over like this and
they become
like a stone that's because they're
deficient in vitamin k2 because calcium
just kind of randomly plugs everything
up vitamin k2 also has been shown to
improve elasticity in your arteries now
think about what that may do to your
blood pressure - it may decrease the
blood pressure because it's making your
your arteries more elastic
there's even cardiologists now that have
blogs out there recommending vitamin k2
for calcified a aortic or which is like
the vessel in your heart to help reverse
that but you'll just have to do your
research on that because it also helps
clean out the joints and the t teeth the
other effects is that it does have
effects on the jaw bone and the
maxillary bone and the teeth so with al
k2 you end up having kind of a narrow
jaw dental problems in need of braces
cavities things like that they did three
clinical trials and they did find that
they did not see any prevention of
osteoporosis by taking calcium and
females which is interesting because I
know people tell you to take your
calcium to ruin osteoporosis but that's
absolutely not true because they three
big studies failed to show any positive
relationship between taking calcium and
preventing osteoporosis and that
includes about taking vitamin D and we
know why because the person is deficient
in vitamin k2 they also found that a
side effect from taking this calcium is
you start getting calcified arteries and
heart problems even heart attacks so by
taking calcium it can create problems
but if you know about vitamin k2 then
you understand why because they didn't
have the dump truck to deliver the
calcium all the way over here now I did
list down below what I recommend is how
much dosage to take vitamin d3 in
vitamin k2 because in order to make
vitamin K T to work it needs vitamin d3
so they both work together and in nature
we always look at things as an isolated
event but really
it's a complex thing that occurs so the
big question is this where do we get
vitamin k2 from our foods well you get
it from the conversion of K 1 to K 2
because K 1 is in all the leafy greens
it's in the grasses so when the cow eats
the grass it then converts it to vitamin
k2 and it's in grass it's in milk cheese
butter from cows that have been fed
grass not grains it's also in goose
liver so people don't eat that they
don't eat butter it's also an egg yolks
from chickens that have eaten some grass
as well so one of the two things that
people or doctors tell you to avoid for
clogged arteries cholesterol eggs butter
cheese whole milk yogurt the exact
things that have the k2 that would have
prevented the problem in the first place
so ok so now it's another one of those
everyone knows and they tell you to do
this right but you can take it as a
supplement but you don't have to
necessarily be afraid to consume butter
from a grass-fed cow or even egg yolks
organic egg yolks or even what I like to
do is I like to have the European
cheeses and because those cheeses are
from cows that are on a mountain that if
fed grass
they're not eating feeding grains mainly
from Europe that's pretty much what I do
I consume a lot of cheese because I'm
from Wisconsin of course but the point
is that you can really help undo this
and improve any osteoporosis if you get
enough of the k2 and have the vitamin d3
and this is actually fascinating because
it actually helps you reverse some of
the aging process with the elasticity of
your soft tissue the joints and the
arteries okay so this is very exciting
so I hope you enjoyed the video and I'll
see you the next one